this gets us into if that money printing
occurs how does it get injected into
there's a long story of how we get to
Bitcoin McCarran yeah I'm dropping
breadcrumbs the whole way I can see um
so we just lost in Hong Kong right for
those they don't know Hong Kong just
announced a 15 plus billion dollar
stimulus plan and in that they're gonna
give 7 million citizens give or take
about 10,000 Hong Kong dollars 1,200
bucks us and what was interesting is
I've never seen this and again you're
you've been around but I have her but
okay well here's here's a trick I
learned
you're not older than me you're more
experienced than me but literally in the
headlines Cash Giveaway the the Hong
Kong government is doing a cash giveaway
it sounds like a [ __ ] lottery but
what they're doing is they're handing
the money to the people rather than just
injecting into the system because the
people who bring me I mean they've
locked up a home and they've got agreed
so fine and everyone says helicopter
money fine let me tell you a story in
Japan back in 1999 98 okay
the Japanese wants to stimulate their
economy so I think it was Paul Krugman
and told them well one of the best
things to do was like I can't remember
this could go so wrong
give it to him but he was advised by
Western economists that the Japanese
were advised by Western economists so
what you need to do is a cash handout
cuz difficut Japanese been monetizing
long before QE long before we even named
it QE right it's not worked never drove
their economy didn't help just kept
things at the margin taking over not
imploding so they decide to issue a
voucher to I think it was people of a
certain age can't member the exact thing
but they were given about it that had a
time expiry on it okay forced them to do
you use it they saved it interesting
wait the people saved it or why
human behavior even with the time
expiration they still didn't like cash
in it yeah because they've been driven
by you know what had happen in the Asian
crisis well it whatever it was so yes I
had some economic effect yes obviously
some people spent it but I'm not larger
group of people saved it than they ever
imagined and that's the other thing is
people talk about fiscal stimulus look
I've followed this in depth in Japan and
the Japanese put this fiscal stimulus
wave to calls of GDP go straight back
down again it doesn't work the only way
you're going to get fiscal stimulus to
work is completely rebuild an economy
which is why I take seriously the Green
Deal because that is a complete rebuild
of economy that could produce more
productive assets over time so in which
case you can do things like you know the
dams in America were built you know at a
suffering that is intelligent use a lot
of fiscal service doesn't go to
intelligent use so we saw this in the
United States back in I think it's 2008
under George Bush there was like a $450
credit to taxpayers yeah that's part of
I think it was a tarp bill or one of the
bills yeah we see it in Hong Kong today
is that just a natural kind of milestone
that we will get back to in the United
States where as we get cut rates to zero
we print a bunch of money there will be
no because we've always given colored
tax relief or tax credit so I don't
think it's a big deal you don't need to
big deal okay no what is a much bigger
deal is when you say right we've got a
depression on ions the the emotional
impact on our population has been
enormous how do we create future
so what are you gonna do in there you
know you're going to rebuild systems
you're going to rebuild things and then
you're going to spend huge amounts of
money and you're going to print it to do
it that's really the what happens now
the the issue is is can the currency
system survive everybody doing that my
guess is no but if it maybe it can maybe
I'm wrong right but the point being is
that is a huge wave when everybody's
doing that at the same time it's much
bigger than a lot of the kind of
[ __ ] stuff that went into top so
that brings us to there's two groups of
people who historically have always
yelled and screamed about this I guess
it's kind of like their dreamed that not
dream James was wrong word but their
predictions are looking more and more
probable every day in terms of hey you
can't print money forever you know it
creates these bubbles there's these huge
kind of negative cycles that occur and
that's the gold in Bitcoin crowd right
and I'm gonna to start put them in the
same crowd of just they have a very
specific yeah mistrusting and they just
have a very specific view of the world
they actually agree on the problems for
the most part they have different
answers as to what the solution is you
told me that your portfolio you've got
cash you've got bonds gold and Bitcoin
you're in that group walk me through
kind of why I think all of it
so the echo is a good question because
it will show you how I try and think
about things
so knowing this was coming because I bet
allocations been around for a while for
me knowing this is coming my view was
that interest rates have to fall the
dollar because of the dollar issue is
going to rise it is going to create a
global wrecking ball that global
wrecking ball is going to cause
everybody to both stimulate massively
and so this pre corona right there's
nothing to do with crow virus it's going
to cause them to stimulate massively and
bail out their pension systems across
the world and that the outcomes of that
means that usually in that environment
gold does relatively well because
there's more fiat versus the value of
gold and it does work well if you look
at I look at gold in a basket versus a
basket of 27 currencies excluding the US
dollar okay it's just not the dollar
that's a driver and you can see then
gold as a currency basically and it does
exactly what especially it goes up trace
iris rate goes up yeah and it goes up
and it protects basically your
purchasing value as a global currency so
it is a global currency and works well
for that and so the the situation is
okay so we're now going to the point
where the dollars are wrecking ball and
there's a lot of printing money in gold
goes up that's a world we've kind of
lived in the last 20 years
but with the problem of the excesses of
this particular cycle and the aging of
the baby boomers and leaving the
workforce and the retirement system I
think we have a chance of breaking it
having gone through 1990 breaking the
system correct the financial system is
what I'm talking about here and having
gone through 2001 and 2008 and seeing
what's left of the imbalances the
corporate credit being one and then how
the system doesn't actually function any
longer and a number of levels the
outcome is going to have to be a move to
something different you know if there
was anything that was genius about the
Satoshi whitepaper is basically
predicting this whatever whenever that
this comes right this is likely to be an
event now so I think of Bitcoin as a
call option on the outcome as these
goals a call option on an outcome
you
thing um has to be a change of the
system we got and that and that means
the way I look at this is is basically
2:14 I think you are hitting right
around this which is we're headed to a
bad situation if the bad situation hits
kind of low to medium bad then gold will
do what it's always done Bitcoin is
likely to do similar to gold possibly it
yeah but just in terms of at least the
way that people are thinking about it
today could change but but the way
people are thinking today's kind of
digital cold narrative if for some
reason we don't hit the load of mid bad
levels and we actually hit really really
really [ __ ] bad which is this kind of
breaking of the financial system gold
will serve as kind of a base case
protection Bitcoin is likely to then be
the thing that outperforms everything
because it is a resetting of them yeah
and it's also aside to that as an out of
that you'll be well aware of that most
people aren't really aware of because
there's too much talk about just about
Bitcoin or cryptocurrencies there is a
brain drain of people coming out of
finance and coming out of technology and
coming out of science that is beyond
anything I've ever seen in my life
and they're basically creating a hive
mind to rebuild financial custody
ownership transfer of everything world
in parallel at the same time and I don't
care what tribe you belong to whether
you're a theory and more Bitcoin or you
know block one or anybody they're all
doing the same thing it is the largest
change that I've ever seen and what it's
incredible is we it's a hive mind doing
it there's not being directed by one
person or one thing everybody's working
on different bits the defy guys there
the transfer of money there that this is
you know Christ I mean tokenization
sports dance is taking the technology
that we have available to us today
and trying to literally rebuild a
financial system for an internet first
type world with in my opinion two key
differences the first is this idea of
separation of state and money and the
second is the
decentralization in a global manner
right and so the reason why I put those
two things there is I always think of it
as like the base unit of account and
then the infrastructure that is around
the financial services around it
historically when we've seen technology
in finance
it hasn't been anything to do with the
base unit of account right it's always
been around infrastructure around
services etc that's happening now and
there's this whole wave of that
occurring which kind of FinTech so not
even crypto really just FinTech and then
also the crypto stuff but this idea that
the actual base unit of account could
change and is actually having in it was
you know only yeah I mean the base unit
of account is having true innovation
right so and I've talked at length about
this like the Facebook Libre thing was a
really big moment and we don't know how
it's going to come out in what form and
there's it won't come in full force at
meanly but basically it was a private
company setting up an SDR based on all
the currencies in the world including
the US dollar so that basket if you
think of my gold basket 27 currencies
this thing should move up and down by
global money supply right so that's the
most stable currency on earth already
and it's issued by private corporation
now what we also know is every single
central bank is building a digital
currency right so they're building that
is some admit it's some Dell but they're
all done that although in India it's on
ramps and off ramps they get it so so
they're building the on ramps and off
ramps the ability of you to pay your
taxes the abilities for them to control
your use of currency within cash flow
stations though yeah within the state
function but they also understand there
is no way of stopping the other rise of
other alternative currencies and
Facebook have said well we can create
anybody can create currency now so you
you're going into a different world and
currencies aren't what we know as
currencies because currencies can have
contracts embedded in them so that is a
whole grain mobile money yeah so that is
a whole different world of everything
but again I love the visuality of like
there's the old system and it's driving
itself into its buffers at top speed we
don't know when that where we're going
to hit that
wall but we're gonna hit that wall
meanwhile it's like there's a whole
world being built can't parallel ya in
parallel and one day if there's a long
enough time you can basically just turn
the lights off on one and go to the
other you you of all people will
appreciate this recently I described a
Bitcoin as a parachute that's masked as
an adrenaline rush and it's kind of like
when you jump out of a plane right and
so it's exactly what you're talking
about is that parallel world that's
being built now the part to me that
really drives kind of my belief in
Bitcoin is that this is not a technology
problem right because just like you said
every central bank in the world is gonna
have a digital currency every
corporation that wants to is gonna issue
these digital currencies we see JP
Morgan in the bank so everybody's
talking about doing it so it's almost
like you get the the technology
horizontal comparison will be very very
similar if not almost exactly the same
to every currency in the world where the
difference lies or the true competition
is in the monetary policy all of the
central bank digital currencies have the
same monetary policy as their their Fiat
counterparts right if you are Facebook
if you are JP Morgan whoever and you
create your own digital currency you're
still pegging it to a commodity or to a
currency so in essence you have a very
big separation there's basically bitcoin
which has this disinflationary monetary
schedule deflationary kind of structure
it's decentralized its programmatic
monetary policy kind of all the things
that we know that Bitcoin brings to the
table and it's a true separation of
state money and they have everything
else and everything else is a technology
quota code innovation but it's the same
monetary policy that we have and so the
competition isn't going to end up being
on a technology standpoint it's gonna
end up being at that monetary policy
level and my bet is slowly and then all
at once we are going to see people
choosing the new monetary policy over
the old because they're gonna see that
old monetary policy for a lot of cases
youdescribe fail them and when they see
it fail them
they're gonna say well what else can I
do and so far we only see one serious
contender on the monetary policy
competition and it happens to be one
that you know looks like Bitcoin is this
kind of speculative asset today but
structurally is very very different than
what we've seen in the past yeah I think
that's right I think it is slowly and
then all at once and we're seeing it
like how many of our friends have got
involved how many people do we know in
that circle gets winder and you're not a
pariah now by saying I've got some
Bitcoin is it's common and it's not now
a sign of that frothy bubble because
even when the price has been doing and
not a lot there are more people coming
into the web people start to get it all
so I just realized is you saw that China
was burning currency because of the
virus so I I had a I have said this is
digital yes I've not tweeted this
because I don't want to kind of poke the
the beehive but there is an element of
the virus is showing that there is an
advantage to a cashless society and I'm
not gonna go as far as to say it's going
to accelerate the move there etc no but
China is burning literally pieces of
paper right to try to kill the fires to
spread the virus yeah and like six
months ago if we would have said that
people be like you're [ __ ] crazy and
again you know we talked about macro
before and how people look at today so
people like it look it's painful to open
an account is still painful most of the
applications are still not good enough
but everybody knows that and everyone's
working on it and there's a hive of
hundreds of thousands of people of very
very smart people all working on it
so the bet you have to take is will they
solve all of those things that make it
such an inconvenience to you today
because if if they will then the bet is
it will go up of course it's like I
wrote this thing but most people don't
see that they got one bitcoins not usual
that's not how you invest yeah I wrote
this thing maybe a year ago now where I
basically went back and I took
screenshots of all the early web
companies so Amazon Google AOL you know
all these things in this stuff will you
remember right I mean just atrocious
user experiences yeah atrocious user
interfaces etc literally the AOL
dial-tone like I put the the recording
of the dial tone as you connected to a
well and little man ran across like I
was crazy stuff couldn't use your phone
at home if someone was on the internet
right all the stuff that at the time was
just that's how it is but the internet
was still powerful enough to get people
to do this now what we're seeing is the
exact same thing play out here with
Bitcoin and digital currencies and kind
of the whole whole digitization I mean
this you know one guy came to my office
the other day in the Cayman Islands and
he's building a decentralized data which
basically replaces AWS by using all of
the data abilities for Internet of
Things people's mobile phones and
creating supercomputers out of
distributed computing networks all right
you know and he's already working and
it's working it's low cost and it's
super efficient and it means that all
the universities can crunch massive data
and have computing power that they could
never afford it's amazing and all of
this going on at the same time right I
mean that's what people to understand
this digital revolution is not just
about the cryptocurrency it's about the
whole [ __ ] thing yeah and part of the
way that I think through this is what's
going on is people are rebuilding
existing systems but they're building it
now for a global digital world and what
I mean by that is historically companies
have let's say you start in the United
States you basically grew as much as you
could in the United States and and
everyone in the board room one year and
said next year is gonna be our big
internationally
expansion and you kind of went from you
know the domestic market to now we're
gonna go international and you spend
much time and resources hired people and
open offices and it all stuff that's not
the world we live in today
what today happens is when you start a
company your global on day one and
you're actually servicing users from all
over the world and so it's a very
different way of building a company but
what it also does is it drastically
affects the growth rate of these
businesses so if you compare you know
we've invested in businesses that look
very similar to an existing financial
services firm but one of it the
old-school way is domestic first and
then international expansion
these guys are global from day one they
actually are going after a much larger
market right in terms of the total
available users that they could have and
so on a percentage basis if you convert
the same number of people the aggregate
number of new users that you sign up is
you know sometimes five seven eight ten
times higher and so you get these growth
rates where companies are going from
non-existent to tens of millions of
dollars in revenue in two years three
years and I think that's part of what
people don't understand is it's not just
the technology it's not that there's a
lot of smart people it's that the
opportunity go from non-existent to
something that is mass I mean finance is
a great example right literally hundreds
of millions of dollars in revenue within
the first two years how do you do that
in the old world you can't right in this
world you can and now all of a sudden
you've got a well capitalized player
that's global because also when you
start something entirely from scratch
there are a bunch of people normal
profits mm-hmm right because if there's
a huge demand so we saw the internet
created supernormal profits and then
social media created supernormal profits
and this will create supernormal profits
for some yep so I mean the opportunity
is enormous I mean it's literally every
single person I mean India what India
when fully digitized you know three
years ago unbelievable so here's a my my
favorite story about India I was there
when they did the D monetization they
took the 500 bill Alok cetera
right after that 18 months later India's
RBI the central bank they're banned they
fight the legacy financial organizations
and banks from having any relationship
with crypto currency exchanges services
etc so they basically said look your
point of failure in the crypto world is
you're still relying on a fiat
traditional bank account except sure if
we cut that off we're gonna really
hamper your ability to build the supreme
court literally this morning in India
just struck down that ban and said you
cannot discriminate the customer base of
these financial services firms based on
what industry they're in and so now what
just happened is basically the entire
India population can start using those
digital currency services exchanges etc
and also bring money from their fiat
bank account into that system and you've
seen that India rebuilt its entire
digital banking system right so I can
now buy milk with a fingerprint mm-hmm I
mean that's so very however Crazy Eights
right the they built without using
blockchain technology their own
technology for the ute ute IM i think
payment system which processes 50 times
faster than Bitcoin could back then when
it came out with you know failure rates
or no intermediary I mean I mean they've
got this thing called India stack and
you look the whole world's going this
way you know there's quite a few smart
Indians I'm half half Indians I'm half
smart but there is India stack India
stack means that you can at a digital
layer now it's a government layer and
not distributed okay I get that some
people hate that whatever that's not the
point the point is or your kyc is in it
so there's ports port so that for
everything you can now I mean you try
opening a bank account in India or a
mobile phone account you know in this
bureaucratic god
you can do it in minutes you know try
and do it here came a nice wait when the
bank counts sometimes it's taking people
three months
it's so onerous there you can do it
three minutes so India snack has all of
your documentation if you died your
medical records are there they know who
you are just by your fingerprint a
friend of mine from India just came here
and when we checked in downstairs at
security he pulled up this app and he
had his passport his driver's license
all this stuff in there and he showed it
to me and I was blown away by literally
in the u.s. would be the equivalent
having your birth certificate your
social security number your passport
your driver's license every you know
your insurance card all this stuff in a
single mobile verify that's verified by
the government that literally you just
tap two buttons and you can show it to
anybody they can scan it they can do
everything yeah it's crazy